OUR SOUTHERN BORDER, YOU HAVE TO
REMAIN IN MEXICO.
MEANWHILE, TALK ABOUT SOMETHING
THAT IS GOING ON IN EATONVILLE,
WASHINGTON.
THE HIGH SCHOOL THERE IN
EATONVILLE, THEY HAVE GOT THIS
PROGRAM.
>> IF YOU ARE ON A SPORTS TEAM,
REGARDLESS OF THE TEAM, YOU HAVE
GOT TO WEAR THIS ANKLE TRACKER.
IT’S KIND OF LIKE AN ANKLE
BRACELET, SURE.
AINSLEY: ANKLE BRACELET OR A
PRISONER.
STEVE: SAME THING.
THEY ARE TRYING TO FIGURE OUT
THE SCHOOL, IN THEIR WISDOM SAID
OKAY, WE ARE TRYING TO KEEP THE
KIDS SOCIALLY DISTANCED.
SO WE’LL GET A CONTRACT WITH
THIS COMPANY FOR THESE ANKLE
TRACTORS.
IT HAS GOT VISUAL AND AUDIBLE
CENSORS WHEN KIDS ARE TOO CLOSE
EACH OTHER.
SO IF I’M WITHIN WHATEVER THEY
SET IT FOR, 6 FEET OF ANOTHER
KID WITH ANOTHER ANKLE MONITOR
IT, GOES O THE WHOLE IDEA IS TO
KEEP THE KIDS APART.
BUT THEN THE PARENTS FOUND OUT
ABOUT IT, WAIT A MINUTE, THE
SCHOOL IS TRACKING THE CHILDREN
AND THE SCHOOL SAID, LOOK, THEY
LEAVE IT AT SCHOOL, WE ARE NOT
TRACKING YOUR KIDS.
BUT ONE MOTHER SAID ANKLE
BRACELETS ARE FOR CRIMINALS NOT
FOR KIDS.
AINSLEY: RIGHT.
SO THEY ARE HAVING A SCHOOL
BOARD MEETING TONIGHT.
ALL RIGHT.
WE WON’T MAKE YOU DO THIS
BILLION WE HEAR THE COMMUNITY’S
INPUT.
THIS IS FROM THE SCHOOL’S
SUPERINTENDENT GARY NEIL.
HE SAYS WE RECEIVED GRANT
FUNDING THAT SPECIFICALLY
INCLUDE PROVISIONS TO SUPPORT
HIGHER RISK ATHLETIC PROGRAMS.
AND WE USE SOME OF THOSE FUNDS
TO PAY FOR ATHLETIC PROXIMITY
MONITORS.
USING THESE MONITORS FOR HIGH
CONTACT AND MODERATE INDOOR
CONTACT SPORTS.
THE MONITORS ARE FOR BOTH STAFF,
COACHES AND STUDENTS ON THE
FIELD REGARDLESS IT IF THEY’RE
VACCINATED OR UNVACCINATED.
IF A STUDENT OR COACH TESTS
POSITIVE WE WILL HAVE IMMEDIATE
INFORMATION COACHES CONTACTS
MORE TIGHTLY DETERMINE WHO MIGHT
NEED TO QUARANTINE.
BRIAN: RIGHT.
OF COURSE IF YOU GET TOO CLOSE
SOMEBODY THAT MAKES SENSE.
SOCCER OR FOOTBALL TOO CLOSE TO
UNVACCINATED PERSON IT GOES OFF.
NOT SO MUCH IN THE LABORATORY
STATE IT HAPPENED.
15-YEAR-OLD GIRL FORCED TO WEAR
ANKLE TRACKING MONITOR FOR
VOLLEYBALL PRACTICE CONDITION OF
PARTICIPATING IN THE SPOMPLET
REQUIRED OF ALL VACCINATED AND
UNVACCINATED.
JUST FIND A WAY TO LET THEM PLAY
MAKING THE RULES.
MASKS WERE A JOKE.
THEY’RE ALL ON EVERY KID’S CHIN.
WE FOUND OUT ABOUT OUTDOOR
ACTIVITY IT’S ALMOST IMPOSSIBLE
TO GET IT.
IT DIDN’T STOP THE OREGON
GOVERNOR FROM COME OUT AND
SAYING YOU HAVE TO WEAR A MASK
OUTDOORS.
STEVE: SO, AND BOTH VACCINATED
AND UNVACCINATED ATHLETES HAVE
TO WEAR IT BUT THIS WAS THE DEAL
THE ADMINISTRATION MADE TO ALLOW
UNVACCINATED KIDS TO ACTUALLY
PLAY THE SPORT.
SO, YOU KNOW, EVERYBODY HAS GOT
TO WEAR IT BECAUSE THEY CAN’T
FIGURE OUT OKAY WHO IS
UNVACCINATED.
AINSLEY: INTENTIONS MIGHT BE
GOOD BUT PARENTS ARE OUTREACHED.
PALM BEACH GOVERNOR DESANTIS
SAID NO MASK MANDATES.
PALM BEACH COUNTY THE SCHOOL
DISTRICT THERE HAS SAID NOW THE
KIDS, NO MATTER IF THEY’RE
VACCINATED OR NOT, THEY CANNOT
OPT OUT OF THIS MASK MANDATE
THEY HAVE TO WEAR MASKS.